it's a little bit more about the
situation in Hong Kong where a
pro-democracy activists say that they
fear the end of Hong Kong after China
and those plans for a new security law
we can get a view from the region now
with the former chairperson of the
Democratic Party emily lau ms larry
thank you for taking the time to speak
to us today with these plans announced
by the National People's Congress how do
you feel about Hong Kong's future well
it looks very bleak China when they
signed the joint declaration with
Britain in 1984 a promise that hong kong
after it's handed over to china in 97 we
can continue to have our free lifestyle
freedoms personal safety and the rule of
law but now this law that the chinese
government is going to make in beijing
without consulting us it's going to
spell an end to one country two systems'
so we will not be able to enjoy freedoms
and the rule of law and personal safety
that is what we fear so it will be one
country one system and hong kong will
become just another chinese city and
that's terrible we spoke I spoke to you
during last year's protests on the
streets of Hong Kong about that
extradition bill and every time there's
been a perceived encroachment by the
Chinese government we have seen protests
do you think this could lead to the
worst we've seen for some time well well
because we have still got the pandemic
so people are a bit worried if they
don't get one to get infected and so but
I think after this pandemic dies down
and we don't know when I think more
people will come out the people will
take to the streets again there's so
much hatred about these police brutality
more than a thousand people have been
arrested in the last year many of them
young people many of them were badly
beaten up and not one single police
officer has been arrested
there is no
justice so just on that the people are
going to come out to protest and now
with this national security law which is
going to be foisted on us it will make
the people more angry and I want to call
on the British government which handed
the Hong Kong people over to communist
rule they have to do something about it
what's happening here is really terrible
what do you want the British government
to do because there are certain I mean
we spoke to a shadow foreign sector set
shadow foreign secretary just a few
minutes ago who thinks that the British
government need to stand up and be more
vocal but past being vocal about it and
calling out what they see as China's
belligerents on Hong Kong what can
others not just the British government
actually do to try to stop China doing
this well I hope Britain will work with
members of the international community
to collectively call on China to stop
not China but the Communist Party to
stop acting in such a barbaric way to
crack down on the freedom say personal
safety but Britain Britain cannot just
abandon the British national overseas
passport holders in Hong Kong
these are British citizens which have
been abandoned and Britain Parliament
should do something about these British
citizens is it good enough if that what
they were to do is to offer obviously
British citizens British passport
holders and Nationals in Hong Kong to
come home to repatriate them is is that
the most the British government could do
or could they go further in your opinion
I think many of these holders of the BA
and old passport would like to be able
to have the right of abode in Britain or
and the minimum Britain should allow
them to come and work or to study with
our visa restrictions and if they stay
in for five years and they can earn the
right of abode these are the things that
many British people have told me that
they
bu Britain has a responsibility for
these people he cannot just turn its
back on us and no Prime Minister one of
your former Prime Minister John Major
once at the Hong Kong people will never
walk alone now we feel we feel very much
alone and we want John Major Boris
Johnson all these people to speak out
for us Emily I can sense your
frustration and anger you know you've
been involved in the Legislative Council
for many years over 20 years and that
body is being circumvented here is right
now the most worried that you've been in
your political career about Hong Kong
indeed yes because in the first 20 odd
years of the handover things were not
too bad
but since President Xi Jinping came to
power in 201 3 things got very difficult
and now this is the pits the Hong Kong
people are very anxious they afraid they
will lose their freedoms their personal
safety the courts are under tremendous
pressure from Beijing so we may lose our
judicial independence these are all the
things that we ventures were tactics and
it seems they are going to vanish vanish
very quickly emily lau thank you very
much for your time we appreciate it and
i'm sure we will speak again in the
coming weeks thank you thank you